a lot to celebrate tonight belfast
barbinstar how does it feel to be
nominated
yeah it's it's amazing you know
you don't it's not why you do it you
know you
put everything into every job and you
hope for the best and
this is a cool thing for the film
they've got so much love tonight and i
think 11 nominations it's a lot um
and then the bonus apartment star being
numbing it as well it's been uh that
that will never happen again for me i
don't think
you're not going to sing for us and all
that again i'm you know that's why i was
having water there just trying to you
know get my voice in shape for the the
singing i'm going to do tonight no you
won't you won't hear me saying for a
while that's enough no no well you're
all presenting right so are we going to
see a reunion up on stage with you in
the ladies
you are going to see that i think yeah
yeah that'll be fun
will it i don't want to say too much
it'll be fun those guys are funny i mean
they're just like nice people in the
world they're icons say or i can't i'm
just like trying to hold on to their
shirt tales you know um yeah what a
treat to work with them did you get into
any texts from like former co-stars or
anything be like i saw you in barman's
star and oh my god i love that i did i
got a lot of love for it from uh various
people people who are like i didn't
i didn't think you were funny maybe they
still don't think i'm funny i don't know
but it was um
it's a it's a favorite for a lot of
people you know that film i think i feel
like it has already the sort of cult
following which is a cool thing we just
talked to the andrew garfield and he
said i love jamie yeah yeah he he
particularly particularly loves it he
can't do it late andrew's one of my best
mates and he came to it very late he
only saw it for the first time um a
couple of weeks ago and uh i know how
much he loves it yeah well i mean he
does the musical theater so that's a
good review that's true i'll take it
okay we you know we have to ask you
about this story everyone's loving the
this old roommate situation you and
andrew and robert pattinson just told us
that he would always get the pity invite
from you guys is that true
no the pity invite i mean honestly no he
was the one i think we were you know
with rob it's always been like
he sort of had success earlier we're a
bit like
does he really fit in with us because
we're not working
and he's working all the time and he
then did twilight was suddenly like a
different stratosphere tales
and we've sort of not caught up but you
know we all then started working more
consistently but um yeah jesus we've
known each other a long time that group
you